the Joe Rogan experience what is this
they are the Gopher t-shirt oh there you
are
[Laughter]
put the glasses on I want to see that
look at you dude oh my god do those days
music keep it here give it here
everybody
do those days feel like like a different
human being when you look back at that
like that's a long-ass time ago and
because of the time yes I'm sure MTV was
like back then and just life back then
it means well don't you have that
yourself just with age you mean yeah I
mean so of course but yeah is it's all
still a part of me that MTV period is so
definitively closed because it's just
not it that will never come back yeah I
mean it was a magical time it was fun
and to this day it can be in the oddest
places it's usually a guy in a suit and
tie
oh that I have I can catch thing like
people drop a a bottle I catch it on the
way down that's my superpower you get to
rest and you get a superpower
that's my catching silver it's super
reflex I'm so good usually a guy in a
suit and tie and all of sudden it's like
and the tie comes off I love that and we
share that and you know that's a shared
experience that that only only our
generation has yeah and then you know
once once B et started getting the you
know I hadn't TV had to buy B et because
they were you know getting world
premieres from Michael Jackson oh so
that was the whole thing there and you
know it just got commoditized they they
were so smart to go on they did the
smarter the people who are running at
the time were very smart to go with
long-form programming they saw it with
the remote control and of course they
already had seen a little bit of it with
what's the first reality show they had
forget what's called the real world real
world yeah so they you know because the
MTB ratings during the day were 0.5
basically and I was always proud that I
would sometimes break
but I had interesting shows that you
know people like to watch like dial MTV
that was the precursor to Total Request
Live Carson Daly show so I did that and
you know that was just the top ten of
the day but people had the idea that
they were making a difference in the in
the chart which they weren't because it
was number one can you guess what was
number one requested every single day
what New Kids on the Block they it was
the biggest problem in MTV the other so
sometimes they just did they didn't make
it on G or we're not playing anything
under number five today o
New Kids on the Block or six G which it
was it was kind of [ __ ] kind of
[ __ ]
yeah didn't that come up really just
charged her with like Twitter
I couldn't Twitter trending toward did
so hard on Twitter they had to stop him
from being number one what they would be
number one better like Taylor Swift or
Beyonce someone would be oh yeah of
course
well if anyone has any idea that this is
fair these these rankings and Hayden's
[ __ ] that it's still weird it's all
weird because everybody's competing
[Applause]